all right let's jump into this first
story from Yahoo news Whoopi Goldberg to
Anheuser-Busch on conservative backlash
don't let them scare you let us scare
you oh boy I love I love Whoopi Goldberg
in the view just overtly threatening
Terror against uh their political
opponents okay I'm being a bit
hyperbolic on that re in that regard
here we go Whoopi Goldberg Coastline
ABC's the view weighed in today on the
recent Buzz wire buzzware Budweiser
controversies reminding the beer maker
that as the shows as the show's end of
our said members of the LGBT community
are Americans too the conversation
follows conservative backlash and calls
for boycott over their partnership with
Dylan Mulvaney Goldberg beginning the
Hot Topic debate by noting that
Budweiser was her beer of choice before
she quit drinking oh before she quit huh
asked what conservatives are so angry
about beer is not a Democrat or
Republican it doesn't have a belief
system it's just beer
well uh I'll tell you I'll tell you it's
because Dylan Mulvaney is the embodiment
of what I call Elsa gate 2.0 the
algorithmic manipulation resulting in
chaotic nonsense content and then Bud
Light was like I got an idea let's fund
more of this Decay and promote booze to
children and so I'm just like bro
everything about what you're doing is a
bad thing but here's the best part the
VP of marketing for Budweiser admitted
their goal was to out Market alcohol to
kids she was like it's a it's an old
dying brand and we got to get young
people like oh is that what you're
saying because Dylan Mulvaney's audience
are like 15 years old you can just
Google it the average user of tick tock
is under 21. that's all that matters and
then obviously Del Mulvaney's audience
is not a bunch of 50 year old dudes it's
a bunch of 15 year old kids that's why
I'm mildly perturbed I don't know about
you guys it blows my mind that Dylan
Mulvaney has a an audience of teens I I
don't see what I'm I'm not a team but I
don't see what is actually well
teenagers in my opinion aren't seeking
out
something of of like
they're being recommended things right
they're not walking to a library and
being like and saying like give me
something that's you know in the vein of
a dystopian no they're showing up the
teachers being like here's the book to
read they're seeing the commercials in
the ads they're young people I'm not
saying that to be mean I'm saying young
people are learning and developing and
being influenced by their older peers so
what's happening is Tick Tock is putting
Dylan Mulvaney in front of people more
and more people that's why I don't like
that they're giving Dylan Mulvaney
sponsorship
your your argument is that the algorithm
is
being is what's presenting this stuff to
kids but you're all the algorithm
responds to what people continue to
watch right I would say yes and no right
so if you go on Instagram you'll see if
the the algorithm feeding you a bunch of
stuff based on what you like but
periodically it sends me stuff I have no
idea why it said it's testing the waters
with certain content You could argue
that with Tick Tock they put this
content out there and it got a response
right but the reality is we already know
from and now especially from the Twitter
files they put their thumb on the scales
and they choose what is or isn't allowed
and if we go back to the uh Rogan
Experience conversation that I had with
Jack Dorsey Vegeta they explicitly said
they were protecting this community and
not other communities so they outright
we're like trans content is under our
overt and explicit protection that means
that if Dylan Mulvaney made if dill
Mobility came out with like a a video
debunking critical race Theory it's not
going to get play Tim cast IRL on Tick
Tock bam end because they choose we
aren't allowed Dylan Mulvaney gets
protected and or promoted and I'll give
you an example I was talking to these
people last weekend about exactly this
and why Dylan Mulvaney is bad and the
easiest way to explain it is
first regular people like Whoopi
Goldberg and default liberals look at
domovany and they're like it's just a
trans person but Don Mulvaney is not Don
Mulvaney I don't believe is trans I
think it's all just part of the
algorithmic machine the example I use is
how young girls are developing Tourette
Syndrome have you guys seen this story
yeah from tick from Twitter uh I'm sorry
from Instagram and Tick Tock teenage
girls start seeing massive spikes in
Tourette ticks because what happened was
a few young women with Tourette Syndrome
got prominent followings and they would
make these videos where they would be
like sometimes it's it's like and then
I'm trying to talk and then they started
young girl started imitating this
content and actually developing this
social behavior and making more and more
content about it that is exactly what
Dylan Mulvaney is Dylan Mulvaney gets
fed this content tries to make content
that will get Dylan Mulvaney famous
figures it out and it's creating a
feedback loop that is melting people's
brains now with the Tourette thing we
know tourettes is not good we don't have
people coming out being like you if a
child identifies as having Tourette's
you should affirm them no one's arguing
that but when it comes to what Dylan
mulvania is doing they're all defending
defending and arguing for more so here's
where we are I want to just to get the
conversation going
Whoopi Goldberg and The View on the left
has realized
they're losing this one and they have
made it explicitly clear to
Anheuser-Busch fear us
because all all I said was this guys
don't buy Bud Light don't buy
Anheuser-Busch you don't got to go
protest you don't gotta make a phone
call you don't gotta do anything other
than buy a different beer easiest thing
in the world and they know and to
respond to that they have to make sure
they remind Anheuser-Busch that they
engage in violence and Terror as an
anecdote I I've seen some of my friends
that are that that are left leaning uh
have a little pushback on the
the bud you know Bud Light uh boycott
and I feel like the the pushback is
because it's it's effective and it's not
I don't think that it's going to have a
significant effect on their bottom line
it's not going to be a monetary Victory
but it's going to be a something where
it's going to inhibit other brands from
doing this kind of stuff because you
know I mean June is only you know a
month and a half in a way away and it's
going to be it's gonna be you know
everything's gonna be Pride for all the
whole month so I think that this is more
about messaging to Brands hey look you
know
at least at least a little bit pull back
on it maybe I guess I think that that's
what they're gonna pick up does that
article also say that beer isn't doesn't
know a political party have they ever
been to a micro Brewery like have you
ever like I if you went and pulled the
people at a micro Brewery about who
their political uh who their political
affiliations are who do you think that
would be it may not have a political
opinion but it knows that it's better
than you at the very least that's the
one thing that I thought she said that
was correct beer should not have a
political party I don't need every
single product that I get to have a
political party attached to it but what
Budweiser just did was the dumbest thing
I've ever done or ever seen I've never
seen a company shoot themselves in both
feet so quickly well I I would agree
with you maybe two years ago but now I'm
like no I demand all of my products just
come out right now and say Trump 2024
and fly American flags that's it if if a
company comes out and they're selling
flip-flops and they got American flags
I'm buying them because I'm at a point
where I'm sick of people like Whoopi
Goldberg I'm sick of what Anheuser-Busch
did if Anheuser-Busch just said I don't
know or care here's beer I bet well it
is what it is but they decided to get
involved and then they apparently they
give more money to Republicans Don Jr
pointed that out and said stop
boycotting them and I'm like no no if
they if if they know that Republicans
butter their bread to the point where
they give more to Republicans then they
should come out and say along with the
money we give you we're gonna apologize
for pissing you off they could not even
do that but you said Phil you don't
think it's gonna be monetary I'll tell
you what what is what is bad there's
that uh what's that guy's name Riley
green the country singer
we had a story on timcast.com he had a
line in his song where he said the
cooler is always full of Bud Light or
whatever he changed the lyrics and
performance dude they're always full of
Coors Light
and and look some people might find that
silly but that does matter to a brand
you were so iconic that a a famous
country music song referenced your brand
that's something you cannot buy and
you've pissed off people to the point
where now your rival your competitor is
getting that value that's bad I wouldn't
be surprised if we see Cora's stock
going up because of this so now the
question is
as we enter The Fray in terms of the
brand Civil War
how far does this go you know like I'm
saying
if I'm gonna buy a bottled water I'll
just I'm gonna order Trump water can I
order Trump water from now on Trump's
Trump you know Trump's got his own
bottled water brand for his Hotel chain
I'm just going to order that and we're
gonna have in the basement you could
probably get it I'm gonna I'm gonna look
it up I'm gonna look it up well we need
to stand firm on this boycott because
one problem with the right is we always
give up our own power like why is it
that we're so quick to just end these
boycotts we don't hold these companies
accountable and then we're shocked when
we see the left continues to win and the
left continues to pull them over because
Whoopi said it herself they shouldn't be
scared of us they should be scared of
them that is very intentional and they
are winning because they will actually
try to cancel a company they'll stop
putting their dollars towards something
but conservatives we always choose
convenience there's more infrastructure
on their side to just hold out and hold
through for us for a lot of companies
like this comes up a lot when we talk a
lot about the TV shows and stuff that we
review right because it's very easy to
say that you're not going to watch
anything from Disney or you're not going
to watch anything from these companies
or Netflix but at the end of the day if
part of your job requires you to
actually end up reviewing their content
because it's still held in the public
you know and the public eye is something
to talk about it's very hard to get away
from that and like you said to yourself
uh yes well I'm saying it's I I don't
I'm I'm not a boycotter in that respect
a lot of times I'll hold the product
accountable if I don't like the product
that's being made whether whether it's
movies or television I will call it out
for what it is when it's bad but for a
lot of those things I don't do the
boycott because I don't find that it's
uh I don't find it effective because
these companies seem to exist in a
post-profit era anyways it doesn't feel
like no matter how much we now you said
they've lost like what six million or
six billion it was six in value
something billions ten of billion
dollars every time that we talk about
this with Disney or something like that
they fire a few thousand workers and
then next year they're just right back
where they were before and I just I
don't see it maybe it just needs to be
held at a stronger pressure point for a
longer period of time but I do think
that we overestimate this is our
go ahead I'm gonna say this is this is
why it's like the most important culture
War battle it's too easy yeah it's too
easy it's too easy for me to be like hey
everybody
you want to help win the culture War buy
a different beer that's it you don't got
to stop drinking yeah you don't gotta go
to a different bar when you go to the
bar you sit down and say but no uh what
do we got the course and it's why it's
so important that companies like daily
wire and Eric D July are making their
own products obviously I'm talking in a
different medium here but making an
alternative to what you're being fed by
these companies is extremely important I
don't think Bud Light did this stunt for
Consumer profit though I think they're
just trying to raise their social credit
score essentially because these big
corporate investing firms they are all
about that the social credit score and
it's called I believe it's uh consumer
equality index or I forgot what the C is
Corporation and Quality Index and that's
like one of the most weighing factors in
the social credit score that these
companies have and that CEI it was
founded by the biggest LGBT lobbying
group in 2002 and so then Bud Light
would already is like a formerly
extremely pro-american group and a lot
of these people hate Americas probably
already seen as in the negative so they
have to like earn their way back forward
exactly yeah thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time